have vanquished Cameron Robinson from
the stage and cleaned it back for myself
hey folks Chris waters here live from
GameSpot's
III stage show and it's Diablo 3 time
not correction not simply teófilo 3 it's
diablo 3 reaper of souls old smits evil
edition which I think Josh Johnny that's
how you have to say it right guys I
believe that's the correct way of saying
it yes awesome well you guys are here
from Blizzard to show off the ps4
version the ultimate evil edition and
we've got a plane right now so let's
just hop right in there and you guys
tell us a little bit about what makes
this so ultimate and evil well first
let's start off with you know when you
get the ultimate evil edition you get
all of the a blow three right so you
know if you get the original game you
get all of all the great classes acts 1
through 4 but in addition to that you
get all the great content released with
Reaper of souls you get act 5 with using
sir Johnny play the beginning of act 5
you get the new class the Crusader
uh-huh you get adventure mode and you
get a slew of really cool console
specific features so very cool features
I mean you know the console I think that
transition for Diablo with Diablo 3 has
been so well received so many people
just sort of really liking the dual
stick feel like killing it's a natural
fit for the action and the fluidity of
play certainly in a GameSpot office
we've got a lot of fans alright so you
know it's out on consoles already what
isn't so you guys got to kick it up a
little bit for the ps4 version alright
well we did I think though some you know
so great challenge is there but I think
you mentioned how good it feels right
and it's really important for us it from
the beginning it really felt like it was
hand built for the for the for the
console and so one of the things we
added is something we call action combat
right so we took all the destruction
bonuses all the massacre bonuses you
find on PC we really sort of pump them
up a level and you know you crazy
school combos to give you some really
significant boosts uh-huh to the
experience we also make sure we would
use a trackpad and the DualShock 4
controller and you know so it really
feels like this is one of the first big
RPGs to hit the next-gen of a platformer
super exciting yeah well you mentioned
the touchpad there what am I doing with
the touchpad so you know what I think we
did with a touchpad is again we didn't
want to come up with a gimmick but this
is a game where you're picking up a lot
of loot and you go into your inventory
right so you can use a trackpad to
select items in your inventory and so
move back and forth and it's just a
different way of getting through your
items but one that feels that makes
great use of that of that feature on the
door right on I sort of giving folks
another option now you mentioned sort of
amping it up here so who is this
sinister fellow with the glowing parts
she is a she's a death maiden so the
story behind you know they'll be
encountering nack5 is it mal fail the
Angel of Death wants to vanquish all
life on the world of sanctuary and of
course this is your job as the player to
say no at this time actually I would
prefer it if you did not asking politely
turns out it's not very effective again
no no it doesn't you know I was
expecting guys get to act 5 it just
becomes dialogue trees and you try to
convince him talk him out of it but you
want a different way I think it was
probably yeah if we just gonna punch him
in the face really hard with my
souped-up launch attacks
of course you know you see on screen
you've got the sort of different
abilities map to the different buttons
and chaining these all together and sort
of working them in a complementary
fashion so that you you have that play
style you've got you know you've got it
all kitted out so much of the Diablo
peel is experimenting with that finding
that niche and then just making yourself
better at exactly right and that's
something that you know we really wanted
to make sure like on Reaper souls and
the open and the evil Edition that your
items need to feel legendary need to
feel epic and you're really gonna change
the way you play you play the game all
right well you guys had a little shout
out in the Sony press conference on
Monday and is revealed that enemies from
the last of us are gonna be making an
appearance in the ultimate evil edition
all right before we talk about the Nitty
Gritty of those those nasty beasts how
did that how did that come about how to
do how did it did you guys think like
you know we have an incredible menagerie
of gross monsters but why more did you
get some more gross monsters you know
great question I think you know Sony's
been such a great partner they have this
they have a love for their players that
for us the Blizzard is really important
and then we were talking about how can
we make the ps4 version feel sort of
unique to PlayStation as well and you
know we have good friends at Naughty Dog
with love The Last of Us and yeah I mean
it just it just it just felt like such a
great way to you know add a feature to
adventure mode by adding a Last of Us
sort of themed dungeon with a monsters
the lighting and they're just a really
sort of cool sort of way to [ __ ]
at a great game so that so you know you
spend a lot of time in the world of
Diablo and then you had you guys added
like a Pittsburgh level it's just really
run down you know something like that
maybe not Pittsburgh but like it's
definitely looks like it belongs and the
last one for the last of us all right
and it's not it's not just like one or
two you guys have brought like a whole
menagerie of clickers and really like
the whole like a whole menagerie the
whole family is there for you to kill
and Luke to kill and loot and speaking
of I any last of us themed blue
you pick up like please switch play or
like Jules kind of ratty rifle I don't
know why you would want that no but the
other cool feature we're adding for
PlayStation 4 is so that when we
announced yesterday which is they shadow
the Colossus transmog look for your
character
okay can you can look like one of the
one of the giant creatures from shadow
the Colossus which looks fantastic
Wow alright last of us Shadow of the
Colossus what else you guys got up your
sleeves here we see it's like something
some Ratchet and Clank you know goofy
weapons coming in there maybe some of my
chains of what a Kratos is chains of
this moment but you know it's we'll see
all right all right well you know I
think with the transition to consoles be
it was came sort of the introduction of
being able to play locally on consoles
talk a little bit about that about the
multiplayer options for ultimate evil
edition well it's it's all the great
mystics you know you had in the in the
original console release right so you
can play online you can play offline but
I think the game really sings when
you're playing on the same couch like
Johnny and I are I'm a playing which is
kind of weird like my fingers when
you're switching their pitching but you
know the team added some really great
features when it comes to you know
playing sort of almost like playing
together one of them is my favorite one
is what we call nemesis kills so like
right now Johnny's playing if any of
those monsters on screen or to kill him
that monster would level up and step
through a portal and then he will go
infest any of your friends game
anybody in your princely so he thighs in
this game and there's some I log on I
might be playing the music at sim
snapped like a Josh and the soundtrack
comes up horror opens up and his nemesis
jumps through it
and says like Johnny's killer and then
he's gonna try to kill me and it's a
really challenging fight now if I kill
him we both get a cool reward if I don't
they level up again yeah what happens if
he starts cutting a swath through you
and all your friends list it he will
continue rampaging then you're in
trouble
yeah well yeah or whoever kills them
like get global get what if it yeah and
then and then that's what Cascades
excellent well we've got a question here
from one of our resident GameSpot Diablo
aficionados the up aficionado you guys
have a term for that with Diablo fan
layers players could use a little work
but will allow it for now Aaron wants to
know any chance of cross saves from the
ps3 version to the ps4 version that is
one of the big features that was
important for us to add is being able to
migrate your ps3 character you know your
level level 60 demon hunter you know
you'll be able to import them into the
ultimate evil edition and you'll be able
to start playing sort of right you know
from a level 60 get them all the way to
level 70 so I was really important for
us to have that that cross-functionality
excellent and of course it's not just
Diablo 3 that you've got here it's also
the Reaper of souls expansion right and
so that's that's a lot of Diablo that is
that is that's why we call it ultimate
evil right it's got all the Diablo I
don't know man I mean what if you want
to release an edition after this where
do you go from ultimate evil you guys
are kind of tapped it out there let's
get where Blizzard finder was all right
yeah have you read our loot descriptions
yeah we got ranged yeah we do alright
Diablo 3 ultimate evil edition cover to
the playstation 4 you guys have this up
and running gear on the
forty-three we do it we do our friends
of Sony booth right across the way here
because their play it took it you know
we have to play remote play we have all
the all the goodness there have you been
seeing some what's been the reaction
from folks so far they just been like
very focused I'm trying to shred their
way through and get some law right there
in their short time well they think
people have been very so very excited
first of all it looks great like friends
on please you know 1080p 60 frames per
second and it mean he looks really sharp
and again it's like the first sort of
RPG to hit the next-gen right so I get
it some some players whose may have
heard up diablo but never had a chance
to play it I'm not gonna get a chance to
find out what the loots all about well
that's not not like now exactly but when
when does this release date coming up
well that's cool usually a blizzard we
say well we can't talk about that yet
you know August 19 August making a scant
two months away if my month math is
correct but I'm not sure it is it's been
a busy day
all right Josh Johnny thank you guys so
much for coming on showing off the hablo
three ultimate evil edition for the ps4
hope have a good show
thank you thank you very much you guys
later